[Música]
ah
en eeuu como en la mayoría de países del
mundo mucha gente se tuvo que quedar en
casa a raíz de la pandemia de el
coronavirus o por eso se registraron
grandes datos de audiencia por ejemplo
en la televisión convencional pero los
podcast fueron en parte también los
grandes beneficiados según apuntan
algunos estudios son muchísima gente se
habría suscrito a este tipo de servicios
durante la época de el coronavirus en el
país norteamericano aunque las
principales plataformas como spotify oa
por muse de que no han dado la cifra
exacta de ese incremento si quien
reconocido que hubo un gran aumento de
suscriptores los estudios apuntan que el
grupo poblacional comprendido entre los
12 y los 34 años serían los que más
escuchan este tipo de contenidos hasta
10 podcast semanales lo que pondría de
manifiesto dicen los expertos a que es
una buena alternativa tanto para los
creadores de contenido como para el
público en general
[Música]
la pandemia del cob y de suelo otorgo
tiempo a los peruanos para acceder a
plataformas digitales que les permite
aprendizaje e información
entretenimiento ya conocer otras
disciplinas las estructuras tecnológicas
más empleadas son books spotify google
podcast y deezer las que tienen gran
demanda este boom tecnológico ha
motivado aún más a la biblioteca
nacional a lanzar su plataforma digital
para préstamo gratuito de libros para
beneplácito de los amantes a la lectura
el organismo digital hizo más de 70 mil
materiales miles de usuarios pueden
acceder a diversos títulos los expertos
señalan que en el confinamiento han sido
los podcasts los que han permitido a
muchos viajar virtualmente escuchar
grandes relatos o ampliar los horizontes
al conocimiento ya no hundirse en el
aburrimiento esta coyuntura le ha valido
ha olido una plataforma inteligente
española ingresar a perú para ofrecer un
sistema educativo de aprendizaje algo
así como un streaming del conocimiento
en la que los usuarios pueden programar
los contenidos que más les interesan o
por inercia el sistema les va haciendo
recomendaciones personalizadas tal como
ocurre en netflix o spotify
[Música]
este año ha habido una explosión en la
popularidad de los podcasts aquí en el
reino unido con casi 7 millones de
personas que escuchan este formato
semanalmente de acuerdo con el regulador
de las telecomunicaciones o con el
podcast ha incrementado su popularidad
24 por ciento este año en relación al
año pasado y los géneros que son más
escuchados son en primer lugar el del
entretenimiento seguido de comedia
noticias y actualidad además durante una
encuesta se descubrió que el 67 por
ciento de las personas realiza otra
actividad mientras se escucha un podcast
cuando se traslada a otro lugar o
mientras maneja y los menores de 54 años
prefieren descargar podcast con vídeo en
la plataforma de youtube entre los
podcasts más populares en estos momentos
se encuentran los de deportes entre
ellos uno que incentiva a las personas
de 0 a 5 km de manera gradual
[Música]